(Risas)
Es fácil pensar así,
sobre todo cuando vemos algunos ejemplos destacados
que dominan la conversación.
Bueno, resulta que a largo plazo no es así.
Morgan McCall y Michael Lombardo investigaron profundamente el tema
cuando estuvieron en el Centro de Liderazgo Creativo.
Encontraron que la principal razón de los fracasos en las empresas
es tener un trato insensible, brusco y acosador.
Siempre habrá algunos casos atípicos que tienen éxito pese a su incivilidad.
Pero, tarde o temprano,
la mayoría de los irrespetuosos sabotean su propio éxito.
A los jefes descorteses, por ejemplo,
todo se les vuelve en contra si están en una posición vulnerable
o si necesitan algo.
La gente no los respalda.
Pero ¿qué pasa con la gente amable?
¿Vale la pena ser cortés?
Sí, claro que sí.
Y ser cortés no solo significa que no eres un imbécil.
Ayudar a una persona a superarse no es lo mismo que no retenerla.
Ser realmente cortés es hacer pequeñas cosas,
como sonreír y saludar en el pasillo
o escuchar con atención cuando alguien habla contigo.
Se pueden tener opiniones fuertes,
discrepar, tener discusiones o hacer una crítica negativa,
pero siempre con respeto.
Algunos lo llaman "franqueza radical",
que implica cuidar de la persona y a la vez hablarle francamente.
Así que sí, ser cortés vale la pena.
En una empresa de biotecnología, con mis colegas encontramos
que aquellos considerados corteses
duplicaban la posibilidad de ser vistos como líderes
y su desempeño mejoraba notablemente.
¿Por qué vale la pena ser cortés?
Porque la gente te ve
como una combinación importante, poderosa y única
de dos rasgos claves:
afectuoso y competente, amigable e inteligente.
En otras palabras, ser cortés no se trata solo de motivar a otros.
Se trata de uno mismo.
Si somos corteses, es más probable que seamos vistos como líderes.
Nos desempeñaremos mejor, y nos verán afectuosos y competentes.
Pero la cortesía tiene aún más ventajas
que se relacionan con una de las preguntas más importantes sobre el liderazgo:
¿qué es lo que más espera la gente de sus líderes?
Recabamos datos de 20 mil empleados en todo el mundo
y encontramos una respuesta muy simple:
respeto.
Ser tratados con respeto es más importante
que el reconocimiento y la apreciación,
la crítica constructiva
e incluso la oportunidad de aprendizaje.
Las personas que se sienten respetadas están más sanas, prestan más atención,
son más propensas a permanecer en su organización
y están mucho más comprometidas.
Entonces, ¿por dónde se empieza?
¿Cómo ayudamos a las personas a superarse y sentirse respetadas?
Lo positivo es que no requiere de un gran cambio.
Las pequeñas cosas hacen la diferencia.
Comprendí que dar las gracias,
compartir el mérito,
escuchar con atención,
preguntar con humildad,
reconocer a los demás y sonreír
tienen un gran impacto.
Patrick Quinlan, exdirector de la empresa "Ochsner Health [System]"
me contó sobre los efectos de su método "3 - 1":
si uno se encuentra a tres metros de alguien,
hace contacto visual y sonríe,
y si está a poco más de un metro,
saluda.
Quinlan explicó que la cortesía se multiplicó,
la satisfacción de los pacientes aumentó
y la cantidad de nuevos pacientes también.
La cortesía y el respeto pueden servir para aumentar el desempeño organizacional.
Cuando mi amigo Doug Conant asumió como director general
de "Campbell's Soup Company" en 2001,
la empresa acababa de perder el 50 % de su cuota de mercado.
Las ventas disminuían
y muchos empleados acababan de ser despedidos.
Uno de los directores de Gallup dijo que nunca habían encuestado
una organización menos comprometida.
Cuando Doug llegó al trabajo el primer día,
notó que había una cerca con alambre de púas rodeando la oficina central.
Había torres de control en el estacionamiento.
Dijo que parecía una prisión de mínima seguridad.
Era un ambiente tóxico.
A los cinco años, Doug había revertido la situación.
Y a los nueve años, batían récords de desempeño
y acumulaban premios, incluyendo "mejor lugar para trabajar".
¿Cómo lo hizo?
El primer día, Doug les dijo a sus empleados
que pensaba exigirles altos estándares de desempeño,
pero que lo harían a través del respeto.
Hizo lo que predicó, y esperó lo mismo de sus líderes.
Para Doug, todo era cuestión de ser firme con los estándares
y bondadoso con las personas.
Para él, se trataba simplemente de los puntos de contacto,
las interacciones diarias que tenía con los empleados,
sea en el pasillo, en la cafetería o en las reuniones.
Si manejaba bien cada punto de contacto,
los empleados se sentirían valorados.
Otra forma en que Doug hizo a sus empleados sentirse valorados
demostrándoles que les prestaba su atención
fue escribir, de su puño y letra,
más de 30 mil notas de agradecimiento.
Y esto fue un ejemplo para otros líderes.
Los líderes tienen unos 400 puntos de contacto como estos todos los días.
La mayoría no lleva más de dos minutos.
La clave es ser ágiles y considerados en cada uno de estos momentos.
La civilidad eleva a las personas.
Conseguiremos que la gente rinda más y dé lo mejor de sí,
si somos corteses.
La incivilidad debilita a las personas y disminuye su desempeño.
Les quita el potencial
tan solo con tenerla cerca en el entorno laboral.
Lo que aprendí de mis estudios
es que cuando estamos en ambientes cordiales
somos más productivos, creativos, colaboradores, sanos y felices.
Podemos mejorar.
Cada uno de nosotros puede ser más consciente
y puede actuar para ayudar a los demás a superarse,
en el trabajo, en el hogar, en las redes,
en la escuela
y en nuestra comunidad.
En cada interacción, piensen:
¿quién quiero ser?
Terminemos con el virus de la incivilidad
y empecemos a difundir la civilidad.
Después de todo, vale la pena.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)